wir gehen weiter zur hannes rafik der am
brocken ist und wir wissen alle aus
eigener erfahrung auch dass es am
brocken immer sehr windig ist das ist
heute gar keinen vergleich und da sehen
wir ihn auch schon hannes du stehst
schon mitten im auge des sturms hat man
das gefühl kann es uns überhaupt noch
hören wie ist die lage gerade bei dir
ich kann euch hören benny müller der
kameramann ist mit allen wassern
gewaschen der muss hier nicht nur vor
der kamera stehen sondern sorgt dafür
dass die technik einwandfrei
funktioniert dass es wirklich
fantastisch ich stehe hier im sturm und
der sturm ist stärker als es jemals auf
dem brocken vorher erlebt habe es ist
unfassbar dass es genauso wie die
wettervorhersagen vorhanden kündigt
haben es ist ich kann mich kaum halten
hier oben wir haben von einem
ortskundigen vorhin die geschichte
gehört das heute tatsächlich trotz aller
warnungen noch eine junge familie mit
kinderwagen und hund es versucht hat auf
den brocken heraus zu kommen diese auch
noch geschafft haben mit ungefähr 23
facher länge des weges
werde derzeit die sie gebraucht haben
hier oben ist alles so es gibt hier
keine gastronomie es ist alles
verrammelt und die mussten dann völlig
nass und und vom wind eben ausgekühlt
den weg wieder nach unten antreten und
verantwortlich wir können wirklich nur
sagen es ist kein ort für wanderungen
schon gar nicht mit kindern schon gar
nicht für ungeübte leute aber der mann
von der von dem naturschutz häuschen
hier unten der hat gesagt es sind nicht
nur die flachländer sondern es sind eben
auch extremsportler die sich bei solchen
witterung versuchen mit der
naturgewalten zu messen die sich dann
selber überschätzen und in not geraten
es ist wirklich nur minutenweise
auszuhalten vor der kamera mit
spezialkleidung und es ist wirklich
wahnsinn was hier oben gerade an wind
ankommt es ist eben 1140 meter hoch
ungebremster sturm führen dieser kuba
ausgesetzt ist bleiben sie fern von oben
von hier oben ja dann wollen wir dich
auch nicht allzu lange aufhalten
vielleicht noch ganz kurze frage du
warst ja auch unten wie ist die
situation in den etwas tieferen lagen
sind die leute da auch in gefahr oder
ist die situation dort halbwegs sicher
also die situation unterhalb des gipfels
in den tälern ist unvergleichlich nicht
zu vergleichen mit dem sturm mit dem
orkan spitzen hier oben aber auch unten
in den tälern vom papst droht gefahr
durch herabfallendes holz die
fichtenwälder sind ja in erschütternden
zustand die dürre sommer haben die bäume
getötet der borkenkäfer hat die bäume zu
toten geritten werden lassen wie also
dem wind völlig ungeschützt um ohne
widerstandskraft ausgeliefert sind
krippen einfach um und wenn die
wurzelballen in dem nassen boden mit
umkippen dann knackt das holz eben nicht
einmal sondern land stürzt der baum
einfach neben einem um ohne dass man
gewarnt wird deshalb raten alle von der
naturschutzbehörde bis zur bergwacht
feuerwehr heute nicht ins freie zu gehen
keine wanderung zu machen auch keine
besorgung mehr zu machen gucken sie in
der vorratskammer gucken sie in den
kühlschrank was sich noch haben zu hause
und bleiben sie einfach zuhause
verlassen sie nicht ihre wohnung ein
danke hannes für diese ersten eindrücke
vom brocken live uns zugeschaltet hier
nach berlin wirklich in sicherheit
erstmal und unglaublich diese familie da
wirklich noch aufschlägen und denkt da
einen schönen ausflug zu machen